remember i was still bitter for like two
years that you said like the the
watching back i know subbed is better
than dubbed i was like what
were you chatting out of your eyes i
mean i still stand by you're chatting
out of your ass
man look i'll say that it's better but
i'm not
saying that the dub is bad the dub is
good the dub's better the dub's better
it's better it's just better
nah
no it's just like it's like it's good
but it's not bad it's like one of the
few dubs that
are you know i mean sorry one of the few
shows that are better experienced than
dubs
just because of the setting and like the
reason why
most anime are better in japanese is
because most of the time
like the setting matches japanese but
yeah it's like
it's in [ __ ] 1930s american
there is only one anime where the dub is
far superior than the saab and that's
panty and stalking
i mean yeah yeah right yeah but that's
obviously because it doesn't even look
like an animator
i think at least for the notable ones
panty and stalking
it is a shittier experience compared to
this it is not [ __ ] i'm
not i'm not saying that the background
is going back going from back a no dub
to sub is like when you have like the
premium triple ply wipes at home and
then you go to the [ __ ] restroom in
like public and it's like the
sandpaper it's grading they're all
it's like 1930s japan and they're all
like kawaii like like some of the
characters
and it's like shut the [ __ ] up sound
sound american you're in 1930s america
sound america [ __ ] i don't know man
like look look listen
to me we need to have you forcibly sit
you down and watch the dub
i've seen you how much have you seen it
i've seen it all
[ __ ] yes i have no way no way is one
of my [ __ ] favorite anime of course
i've seen the dub and also because
you shut the [ __ ] up about the dumb so
i'm like all right fine
until i watch you watching the duck i
wanna i wanna sit behind you being like
[ __ ] do we appreciate this i'll do i'll
do a reaction video
please stop fighting i'll do a reaction
video to me watching the job and then
you can do a reaction video to my
reaction video
all right how's that i think any okay
here's another question can we just get
on
please okay can you name any of the
characters
that you think are better in the sub
than the dub like which one do you think
uh or like is there any
dub characters it's not it's not
particular characters it's just
overall because maybe it's because i did
watch the sub first i don't know maybe
if i watch the dub first might be
completely different i don't know like
lad russo is like one of my favorite
dub performances of all time yeah of
course lad russo is [ __ ] incredible
yeah and he's good in sub
but like i don't know i mean i don't
know maybe it's because i understand the
language it hit different
i'm just if you okay i'm just saying
maybe it's because i understand the
language and
i understand the small little
inflections that might go over a lot of
people's heads
that i appreciate the sub a lot more
than most people i mean you just okay
even just like give me like two second
sample of the voices when you
listen to like the gravel in lad's
english voice in baccano it's like god
damn okay but
okay but hold on from from your logic
right you've only brought up lad
yeah la okay well i think isaac and
miriam are also better
i think isaac and miriam sound the
[ __ ] same no no it's
it's [ __ ] in japanese it's voiced by
cream from sonic and it sounds like
crazy
and it's it doesn't sound right at all
okay and also in the sky
but hold on a second if if that voice
actor didn't do cream from sonic then
maybe you'd be like okay this is pretty
good
sonic the hedgehog to anyone that hasn't
watched this you don't need to have
watched it but
like again and also in the in the dub
they cut out a lot of the reaction
noises like huh
or like a bunch of them which is [ __ ]
fantastic cause i think it doesn't suit
back i know having the
uh and [ __ ] miriam sounds like
[ __ ] cream the [ __ ]
what's the rabbit that's it nutting
every two seconds and she says sugoi
every two seconds it is so grating
seeing an american 1930s person going
with a tommy gun going sugo it's so
weird i don't know i hate it i don't
mind it because it's [ __ ] anime
oh i i what did you say one of the
episodes it's just cartoons
yeah it's just carter it's just a
japanese cartoon bro chill the [ __ ] out
we all know that someone has to get
angry enough oh my god of course
every time dude every anime has to have
that
one faction of a toxic city right i
thought i cared about the buck no dub
and then i realized man maybe i don't
care about the ball no
i really don't i really don't i just
think you know
scientifically speaking it's it's better
it's a chinese cartoon voiced in english
like chinese it's just chill out there
sorry
this man this went down oh my god
what were we talking about i don't even
know what exactly oh yeah we're talking
about no no we were talking about our
favorite people
why don't we do this every time tangents
are a healthy part of conversation not
when it goes over to like how did it go
from [ __ ] oh yes
i love j michael tatum too [ __ ] cream
from sonic the hedgehog i felt like i
could just could have just gone for like
a toilet break and just let you guys
duke it out
you know i i just care about the things
that i care which is not me
what's the meme on the subreddit again
where it's like i love how connor
interjects with an opinion and thinks
he's always right
hey i
[ __ ] hate when i listen to your
podcast when it's like three people who
are like
oh yeah yeah i guess you have a point
yeah i mean i guess i can understand
where you're i want somebody's like
[ __ ] you you're wrong and it turns out
that person is completely
in the wrong right one they're like i
don't give a [ __ ] it doesn't matter
that's last episode so what you're
saying is you're playing the
you're you're playing they're playing
the antagonist you're playing the
antagonist okay listen
right i don't give a [ __ ] and if i'm in
the moment i'm gonna say what i say with
full confidence and i'll go home later
that day and i'll be like
i think i was actually wrong actually
yeah we've recorded it
big regret because i've talked to you
enough time to know that you do that
so many [ __ ] times on the podcast as
well so i'm just like
you know what sometimes i'll just let
him out the candy and just let him
realize sometimes
sometimes you do it on the same day
you're like we would have a conversation
in like the afternoon and then as we're
having drinks on that you'll be like
i might be talking out of my ass i'll
totally realize later on i'm like yeah i
was actually
completely in the wrong in that pool
yeah yeah you know i'm glad that i said
it with confidence at least
i mean look the bottom line is don't
take what we say
all that seriously all right take it
with a grain of salt this is just three
boys just having a [ __ ] laugh
yeah i i got we're not like i don't know
we're not like an authority or anything
like that
no i see a lot of people who comment
being like i can't believe they
misquoted something or accomplished they
spread misinformation and it's like no
this is just
three boys having a conversation that we
would have off camera yeah this is
exactly how we talk off-camera and i'm
sure you have conversations with your
friends all the time where yeah you
should
absolutely [ __ ] out of your ass right
exactly so if we say anything that's
incorrect
if i'm actually confident about it don't
take that
like that in other words don't ever take
us seriously